we told members of the wack pack that
Howard me was sick and maybe we need a
plan B Bob always up first he did a
sample read it was well you decide if it
was good or bad to be a successful and
business owner you'll need all right
hiring payroll advertising you're in
charge of it all and then some so you
can't afford to let things like legal
for business formation you have some you
have enough to worry about without
getting bogged down and the intra C's of
contract reviews so you know maybe you
think about starting your own business
up these people it's where it's at Wow
Wow
Bobo were you choked the intricacies I
thought your head was going to explode
you didn't even complete one sentence
Bobo not one sentence lately did you're
right try that word again that's noise
and I sounded I'm not gonna interrupt
you and who you get it right you take it
take your time and then when you think
you have it locked in say oh that's it
lock it in I'm gonna tell you that's
wrong do you want to try it again it
sounds like you're saying in crow seeds
like crows have seeds in crow's feet and
crow's feet you are saying bubble crow's
feet yeah Baban
okay let me do Alton intricacies
intricacies all right that's it lock of
it Jim Croce
you